we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p this voicemail asks about
something we have not discussed on the
show before but it's really important to
take a listen to this hi I'm Christine
I'm from Los Angeles I was watching The
Morning Joe program and they mentioned
that shadow banking is largely
unregulated what the heck is shadow
banking can you explain it thank you
yeah so shadow banking as the name
suggests is banking that happens in the
shadows and specifically it means out of
the view of regulators like it's sort of
in the shadows from average people but
it's also more importantly out of the
view of regulators and this can happen
in in two different ways one is non-bank
financial intermediaries that don't
accept normal banking deposits are often
unregulated so this can include hedge
funds
it can include certain types of
derivatives and many other examples the
other sort of meaning or version of
shadow banking is major financial
institutions that are normally regulated
whose banking activities are regulated
but who are working in a specific type
of product that is less regulated so you
might have like a hedge fund that's part
of our associated with a regulated major
financial banking institution but not
every single one of their activities
would be equally regulated and if it
sounds sketchy it is a major factor or
it was a major factor in the 2007-2008
financial crisis and a key sort of
common factor in a lot of these shadow
banking instruments is a massive massive
leverage leverage of course being that
you use a little bit of money to get a
whole bunch more money on credit which
you then invest and of course the risk
with that is that you can end up losing
more than the amount of money you have
like a simple example would be if you
invest in stocks on margin
right if you invest a thousand dollars
in stocks cash that thousand dollars
could become much much more or it could
go to zero and the worst that would
happen is you lose the thousand dollars
if you invest on margin you might use
those thousand dollars to secure ten
thousand dollars in credit you now have
ten thousand dollars invested but you
really only have a thousand dollars in
actual cash if the ten thousand dollar
investment goes to zero even though you
only started with a thousand actual
dollars you owe someone nine grand you
are out 9 grand
and that is why leveraged financial
instruments can very quickly become
extraordinarily risky so yeah the more
money that's tied up in shadow banking
the more credit that is built up in
shadow banking entities the more risk
that exists in the financial system so
good question haven't talked about it
glad for the opportunity on the bonus
show today we have had a shark attack in
Cape Cod very close to Boston where a
man died I am going to talk about it and
more interesting interestingly I want to
talk about shark attacks as a cultural
phenomenon which which is very
interesting
doesn't make this death any less tragic
we will talk about scam phone calls on
mobile phones and other topic of
interest to me and we will also talk
about the growing list of questions
about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos --is a two
billion dollar philanthropic fund thank
you for joining me today one more
program from Paris tomorrow and then I
will be back at David Pakman show
studios at the end of the week